what does lazy look like to you each
year we get better and better at doing
nothing but this idea definitely takes
the cake this is what if and here's what
would happen if you never left your bed
the average person spends roughly 1/3 of
their life in bed the below average
person says that's not enough time we
all have those days when getting out of
bed seems like a real chore ok maybe
that's everyday but we do it anyway
even if it does take a few hours don't
you think it's time we start saving time
do you feel like hitting the snooze
button indefinitely morning noon and
night it's bedtime 24/7 I'm not talking
about sleeping forever I'm talking about
never leaving your bed again what in
2014 NASA actually paid someone eighteen
thousand dollars to lie in bed for 70
days that's right a person was paid to
literally do nothing and he hated it the
experiment was meant to test how future
astronauts might be affected by longer
space flights like for when we
eventually go to Mars but an interesting
finding that might surprise you is
staying in bed sucks it's also kind of
dangerous
before committing to a lifetime in your
bed you should know that it's the
dirtiest object in your room your bed is
home to countless dust mites a variety
of bacteria and seventeen different
types of fungal spores but don't go
rushing out to buy a new mattress
because you're a big part of the problem
those 500 million skin cells you shed
every day a large portion of them end up
in your bed along with traces of the
makeup or lotions you wear and crumbs
from the late-night snacks you eat but
you're not the only one enjoying a
midnight feast whether its skin crumbs
or any other type of particle the
microbes you lie with love the whole
menu if you're still on board with
staying in bed forever then let me
remind you of the simple unavoidable
displeasure of sweating under normal
conditions humans can produce
approximately ninety eight liters of
sweat every year while in bed and under
abnormal conditions like spending all
your time there your bedding would soak
up nearly 300 liters of sweat per year
to keep it from soaking up anything else
think about your bathroom options are
you cool with bedpans catheters or going
back to diapers of course cleaning up
would definitely require some assistance
but if this is a world where nobody
leaves their bed then whoever's making
really sophisticated robots with a good
bedside manner is about to become very
rich think about it a robot wouldn't
only be there to keep you clean but to
keep you from turning into an amorphous
blob of rotting skin deteriorating bones
bed sores for example are the result of
prolonged pressure on the skin left
untreated bed sores can lead to skin
bone and joint infections in extreme
cases they can even cause skin cancer
a lifetime in bed would require a lot
more activity than just tossing and
turning you'd need to relieve pressure
on your skin and exercise your muscles
to retain bone density and muscle mass
think of your body like a sexy sports
car you might be worried about
scratching the paint but you've got to
drive it regularly to prevent carbon
buildup and to keep it running at peak
performance if you lie in bed all day
without moving your body your bones and
your muscles will eventually degenerate
to the point where you'll no longer be
able to use them lack of exercise would
also reduce blood flow to your heart and
your lung capacity would decrease
because lying on your back would mean
there'd be gravity pulling on them to
let in more air so while you're lying in
bed literally relying on robots to keep
you clean active and for lack of a
better word healthy all you'd really be
able to do is read play video games
watch movies eat sleep think and talk
needless to say you'd probably be pretty
depressed this doesn't mean that people
who are confined to a bed or who are
largely immobile aren't capable of
leading rich and fulfilling lives
there are many among us who do but if
you are able if you are healthy if
you're happy and you know it clap your
hands
shake a leg jump dance that's what it's
all about it's an excellent time
detective I'll just never sleep within
reason
have you ever wondered what would happen
if you no longer need it sleep we
already have the answer for you but
that's a story for another what if